[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débrief du doc dans ce
numéro les questions du documentaire sur
les traces de gandhi est actuellement en
ligne sur notre site internet
rt france a pointé v et pour en parler
avec nous louis campana président
fondateur de gandhi international une
association en faveur de la pensée et
gambier et qui prône la non-violence
louis campana merci d'être avec nous
donc merci monsieur campana alors
première question qu'avez vous pensé du
documentaire en général tous les indiens
considèrent eux grandi comme le père de
la nation et par conséquent tout le
monde chacun parle un peu la
personnalité puis on dit et c'est
remarquable de voir l'état de l'état
d'indiens différents vivent des choses
différentes je reconnaître que dans la
pensée ils ont là les faits les gestes
de gaudi alors vous êtes président
fondateur de gandhi international je le
disais vous avez aussi écrit des livres
sur lui réalisé des documentaires sur
gandhi pourquoi lui pourquoi gandhi
j'écoutais moi ça fait cinquante ans que
je suis rentré dans une recherche de
cohésion de cohérence de ma propre vie
et j'avais rencontré les communautés de
l'arche de l'un des deux astres qui est
un disciple de gandhi et qu'il a en
conteur de 936 et 37 à warda lorsque il
a fait son pèlerinage aux sources
et pour lui rencontré gandhi dans un
contexte européen qui préparait la
grande guerre c'était pour lui
l'occasion de voir qu'il y avait une
autre façon de voir les choses d'une
façon de vivre la réalité comme bossi
donc il décrit un peu cette rencontre
avec gandhi comme d'un oasis de verdure
dans un monde désertifier par le bon
sens est livrée à la violence et qui n'a
pas qui n'a pas en rangs soit de raison
de désespérer alors votre association
comme inscrire sur le site montre
l'actualité de la pensée de gandhi face
aux immenses défis contemporains qu'est
ce que cela veut dire concrètement pour
écouter c'est résumer un peu pardon dit
lui même dans son premier livre qui
s'appelle lynch varades qui avaient été
trahis et par la drass justement sur le
titre de leur civilisation est haute et
l'autre délivrance eux l'ont dit voulait
montrer par là que la civilisation dans
lesquelles ils vivaient soit en
angleterre soit en afrique du sud était
une civilisation que qu'elle pourra est
nommé de diabolique dans le sens où au
sens littéral du mot qui veut dire lire
croche-patte ou un mensonge ou le bas le
fait de mettre des bâtons dans les roues
des gens voilà dos qui considère que la
société anglaise de l'époque est une
société dangereuse parce que détruit la
personne je pense que c'est assez
compliqué de résumer en quelques mots
mais si vous pouvez le faire
comment vous décririez la pensée
kantienne lingots de penser le lundi de
dire écoutez votre voix intérieure
la petite voix intérieure à l'intérieur
pire elle va vous dirigez sur une unité
de vie et aide dans leur dans le
reportage que nous avons lu nous voyons
que les gens qui ont adhéré à cette
façon de vivre ont développé une vie
personnelle
une vie de chaque jour qui les mène vers
une autonomie de la personne et ça se
sent quand leur façon de parler
alors justement vous parlez vous parliez
d'autonomie et d'indépendance c'est pour
ça que la quenouille c'est un peu le
symbole de gandhi vous propose cet
extrait pour comprendre pourquoi cet
objet avait tant d'importance à ses yeux
regarder pour répondre à nos besoins
vestimentaires
nous n'avons besoin de filets qu'une
heure par jour
et si chaque personne devient autonome
il serait impossible de faire pression
sur et leurs mamans sont que c'est
suffisamment fort vous voyez si
j'insiste trop ça va casser si vous
sentez que la tension est correct tirés
et roulés le fil si votre esprit est
calme ce sera parfait si vous êtes sans
cesse perturbé il va se rompre ont
constamment ses traits méditatif
cela repose sur la concentration
ils produisent leurs propres vêtements
ils sont indépendants
on vient de le voir la quenouille
monsieur campana finalement c'est une
façon d'être indépendant autonome oui
tout à fait et c'est la raison pour
laquelle lorsque je suis rentré dans
cette communauté mondiale en 1970 j'ai
appris à filer la laine
j'ai fait des couvertures l'effet des
durs les films dvd ponchos et le lâchant
pièces que vous voyez que j'ai sur moi
là est une chemise que j'ai acheté en
had précisé mois à ward a là où il ya eu
le dernier achat de non dits et le
gandhi avait bien demandé à tout le
monde là-bas d'être autonome
alors cette chemise par exemple elle et
le coton a été planté rico
les gars des filets tissés par les mêmes
personnes pour pour concrétiser cette
nécessité de l'autonomie en europe
le coton ne sera pas la laine bon c'est
de moins en moins mais ce que moi je
propose à tous les disciples de l'aunis
fait d'avoir leur propre jardin potager
et celle de travail un levier travaux
que je fais actuellement c'est de
pousser les gens à avoir a autres
autonome au niveau de l'alimentation
justement vous parlez d'alimentation de
consommation un gandhi voulait également
que l'être humain se sépare un peu de ce
mode de vie roux consomme où on nous
pousse un peu acheter toujours plus
encore et encore tout est fait en ce
sens je parle notamment de la publicité
est ce que la nouvelle génération
peut-être vraiment se défaire de ce mode
de vie daou est-ce que c'est pas un peu
trop tard ouais bah écoute et revenir à
la filature de la laine ou bien revenir
aux travaux de la terre
je pense que les constitutions actuelles
ne nous permettent plus les gens les
gens à même les jeunes de moi je limite
enfants donc je sais ce que j'ai à part
quelques-uns qui sont capables d'avoir
une activité physique pour travailler la
terre
eh bien vous assure que c'est pas c'est
pas quelque chose qu'il ya pas
l'endurance 1 la société que nous avons
vécu pendant les trente glorieuses nous
à excellent extrêmement affaibli au
niveau de l'endurance et on eut rendu du
bon sens des choses
et est-ce que selon vous on peut revenir
à un mode de vie sain oui mais alors
sera demandé énormément de conviction de
cohérence et de persévérance
on l'a vu aussi dans le
commentaire l'héritage de gandhi s'étend
bien au delà de l'invs on l'a vu avec
ces motards américains mais évidemment
pourquoi fascine-t-il toujours autant
aujourd'hui en 2020 et bien précisément
parce que il
il est il est dans une résistance dans
un dans une interrogation par rapport à
ce que les politiques les économistes
les multinationales nous à vous les gens
se rendent bien compte qu'ils sont dans
une dans une servitude permanente où on
ne choisit pas sa vie le marié souvent
lorsque je fais des conférences de
vircom les classes moyennes actuelles
c'est à dire ceux qui sont capables
d'avoir un appartement une voiture deux
emplois sont dans une machine à laver
dans lequel ils sont lavés race et
essorés jusqu'à la retraite
ça veut dire que on passe à côté sa vie
on passe son temps à faire ce que on
doit faire pour continuer à vivre son
vivre c'est dur ce que je vous dis là
louis campana on va finir assurément
tout cas la première partie puisque
c'est l'heure de la pause on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour la suite de
ce décrivent du doc a tout de suite
bienvenue si vous nous retrouver pour ce
débrief du dock avec louis campana et on
parle avec ce président fondateur de
l'association gandhi international du
documentaire sur les traces de gandhi
alors justement ce qu'il a fait et
gandhi c'est qu'il a aidé lundi à sa
décolonisation justement la
décolonisation assez trop souvent fait
dans le sens dans la violence
racontez-nous monsieur campana comment
gandhi par la désobéissance civile par
des actions pacifiques
il a réussi à obtenir le départ des
britanniques est bien une des premières
choses qu'il a faites lorsque dix
indiens d'inde lui ont demandé de
revenir d'afrique du sud pour justement
commencé ce travail de décolonisation la
première chose qu'il a faite c'est de
quitter son habit de civiliser anglais
d'avocats pour revêtir le paille et le
bâton donc c'est déjà un 2 pour lui
c'est un changement de cap entier la
décolonisation passe par l'interrogation
qui est faite aux indiens est ce que
vous êtes capable de devenir libres pour
être des colonisés parce qu'il faut
savoir que la plupart des indiens
avaient trouvé un modus vivendi pour
collaborer avec les indiens avec les
anglais surtout ceux qui avaient les
emplois administratifs et guy daniel
relativement violents vis donc la
première des choses qui s'élevait à
maurice que vous êtes capable
d'indépendance et l'indépendance qu'est
ce que c'est c'est pas seulement le fait
de dire nous sommes un état indépendant
est ce que chacun de vous est prêt à
être des colonisés dans notre tête
être libre à devenir autonome et c'est
la raison pour laquelle un des premiers
outils qui leur a donné
c'est le la commune comme vous en
plaidant en fait nous c'est plutôt le
roux mais on n'a pas ça le roux r
l'élément le plus important où les
hadjar ont compris c'est la marche du
sel les les anglais voulaient faire
payer le feraient les frais de la
colonisation par l'impôt et à des infos
les plus impopulaires qu'il soit celle
l'impôt sur le sel
d'abord parce que le sel a uniquement
sur les pourtours maritime et qu'à
l'intérieur des terres n'y a pas de sel
écoeuré c'était une bonne occasion de
faire entrer de l'impôt et un mondial
ravi e on va se libérer de la
colonisation en se libérant de la peau
qui étaient dus au sel et il a fait
cette marche qui a duré en 1932 d'agneau
et une quarantaine de jours et chaque
jour il expliqué et il faisait savoir
par la presse qui valait désobéir est
allé prendre le sel lui même il l'a fait
il a évité tous les indiens faire pareil
et il a demandé à ses amis un gain à ses
amis anglais de me mettre en prison
parce qu'ils avaient désobéi
et il a dit au juge vous devez me
condamner et si vous voulez pas me
condamner
eh bien vous devez vous des maîtres de
votre rôle de juge me remettre en
question
c'est à cet impôt voilà ça a été un des
moments les plus forts
cette désobéissance civile collective
alors pendant des années ou précédemment
il ya eu des des américains bien eu des
des gens qui ont montré une
désobéissance personnel par rapport à
l'or alors gouvernement gandhi lui a
voulu que ce soit quelque chose qui
deviennent collectif et que ce soit tout
un peuple qui désobéissent désobéissance
civile action pacifiste est ce que ça
pourrait arriver aujourd'hui en 2020 ça
existe en europe
enfin on a été on a su on a été capable
de désobéir
par exemple en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire il ya eu pas mal moi j'ai
participé il ya trente 30 40 ans on est
rentré dans les centrales nucléaires on
a récemment on a été battus pour la
liberté des paysans de l'artac on a
également ses paquets contre les ogm on
est allé je n'ai à new york devant l'onu
lorsque le président américain voulait
bombarder l'irak et demandé à l'onu de
prendre également des dispositions pour
anéantir le l'irak
vous savez très bien que ville pas que
d'autres 20 chefs de gouvernement ont
refusé et nous avons fait à fond là nous
l'avons tué un jeune de huit jours à new
york pour demander à l'onu de ne pas
accepter cette condition est de laisser
les américains partir tout seul
voyez donc la désobéissance civile c'est
quelque chose qui qui se fait toujours
actuellement en inde il ya un camp le
marché djaidia garde quelques interrompu
par le confinement qui était une des
lignes démarche de paysans sans terre
ils sont pas
de glee et qui devait arriver en octobre
prochain après un nom de marche à genève
et bien c'est le marché qui arrêtait pas
de confinement et je ne sais pas quelle
suite va y avoir on nous verrons ça en
2000 d'un tiers mais vous voyez ce
travail
ce travail de désobéissance civile est
permanent on peut dire que martin luther
king
on a réussi lui aussi collectivement à
résister à un grand pays comme l'elysée
ça gênait vous parliez à l'instant des
centrales nucléaires on est en plein
débat sur les énergies renouvelables les
énergies propres dite verte
il y en a une à laquelle on ne pense pas
forcément
regardez vous allez comprendre l'énergie
est au coeur de toute idée de
développement ou de toute économie
ainsi chaque fois que nous pensons aux
énergies renouvelables
nous ne parlons que d'énergie solaire
devant ou d'autres choses mais nous
oublions toujours qu'il existe une autre
source d'énergie
nous avons un peu d'énergie dans notre
corps pour accomplir du travail manuel
cette source d'énergie n'a jamais été
considéré comme tel dans les débats sur
l'énergie s'est toujours considéré comme
du travail et non comme une source
d'énergie renouvelable
donc si vous commencez à percevoir le
caddie tels que gandhi l'envisager au
travers du prisme de l'énergie
cela vous donne une perspective
totalement différent cervelle et les
fans passent par carole bouquet de
monsieur campana qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce que vous venez d'entendre
robert complètement travailler
travailler scène c'est développer son
énergie sa créativité
et puis là la meilleure façon de course
de ne pas consommer d'énergies
renouvelables ou fossile du n'importe
quoi c'est de ne pas s'en servir et par
conséquent de tels capable de pas sa
propre énergie
deux souvenirs ses besoins on a parlé
que dalle heures c'est l'autonomie c'est
la dépendance ça passe pas mal c'est
évident très rapidement avant de
conclure on le voit les manifestations à
travers le monde entier dégénère que ce
soit la police qui intervient jets d'eau
gaz lacrymogènes des casseurs qui se
mêlent aux manifestants cette tranche un
peu beaucoup avec ce que promet gandhi
quel regard portez-vous justement sur
cela écoutez d'un bon keita à ça à sa
justification à la violence et il le
passe on diffère de la drogue et à une
bonne des plus violents parle a le droit
ou bien à part par habitude il disparaît
alors ce qui est important c'est c2c de
dire quand est ce que le pouvoir sera
non plus entre les mains de l'état mais
entre les mad de ceux qui sont en bas
des plus petits
c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on peut
accepter
il faudra qu'on trace un jour que chacun
puisse décider de sa propre vie
l'artisan dansant dans son atelier le
paysan dans son champ ensuite le village
le village qui prend des décisions pour
lui-même solidairement à d'autres
villages c'est à dire tu es au mode est
plutôt que le pouvoir viennent d'en haut
il
il y à une baïne bay il n'est secret en
bas est ce que dans les figures
actuelles connu un célèbre il y en a une
selon vous qui se rapprochent de cette
pensée gambienne bas il ya un diagonale
qui est un ingrédient indien qui a
réussi avec ekta parishad qui signifie
forum unis a rassemblé tous les
personnes qui sont en grosse difficulté
en inde
petits paysans paysans sans terre des
pêcheurs sans littoral des réfugiés de
l'intérieur ekta parishad c'est donc
c'est ce forum qui donne la parole à
tous ces gens là et qui les invite à
résister par les moyens non violents
bon je peux jt également arrière acné
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
aussi lanka qui fait un gros travail
et puis bon il y à des acteurs même en
europe il y à il ya par exemple de
capucine et en italie il déclare qu le
pouvoir et pour tous il est de tous
il ne faut pas le laisser entre les
mains des états louis campana
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec on
sur rt françois fait vous êtes président
fondateur de gandhi international merci
à vous c'était le débrief du dock une
émission que pour que vous pouvez
retrouver sur notre site internet
rt france point tv merci à tous
[Musique]